do a little quick intro we will talk
about my life today a lot of you guys
are interested in personal stories and
might well be living in fight now hey
what's going on YouTube I was doing
intro that's very sexually suggestive or
very um baby touch arica now I've been
living in LA for the past I say about
five years and then living in this
[__] crazy ass city I've got a lot of
stories now I know a lot of you guys out
there wonder well how do you have so
many stories and here's the reason why
is because you [__] don't go
outside you see when you go outside you
interact with people guess what you will
have new experiences even when you guys
are outside I see you there you're on
your [__] phone you're checking your
snapchat your Twitter whatever and you
don't see what's going on around you so
of course you don't have [__] stories
you're not living but now there's a
general truth about me I have really bad
luck especially when it comes to people
I seem to always get into these weird
confrontations whenever I go outside
there's always a 50/50 chance that
somebody's gonna do something that
requires me to get like you know my
swelling and say let's go cook and I'm
not a confrontational person I don't
like fighting I don't like getting angry
I don't you know despite this channel
there's like half anger that's just for
comedic purposes so I'm going to tell
you about the story that happened with
me and Mary oh no I told you guys
earlier that I love going to Little
Tokyo in LA that's like a spot and one
of the places that I normally go eat
izakaya place where we get our yakitori
on would you like you know these grilled
little meat skewers is hot it's not no
as you guys all know all the parking
spaces in LA are smaller [__] and I had
this white Jeep Grand Cherokee so I see
one spot in the parking lot I go ahead I
get in there really carefully but it's a
really tight spot and of course this car
park next to me is this bright orange
Mini Cooper yes that shit's a [__]
abomination as me and Muriel are getting
out the car I'm getting out my side but
this Mini Cooper is part of super close
to me so I'm trying to squeeze on that
with my fat ass and of course my big-ass
belly I exhaled once and it opened and
it slightly tapped the car next to me
now of course I felt bad so I squeezed
my fat ass on out of there to check to
see if there was any damages right I am
a decent human being now I look down at
the car no damages but of course the
owner of the car has some
else to say now mind you I baby tapped
it I'm talking about that noise right
there maybe even softer than that
so the dude comes out the car and he
just starts screaming what the [__] what
the [__] did you do this is my brand new
[__] car
so he's screaming at the top of his
lungs yelling at me in my [__] face
and mind you I'm still calm I look over
at Mariel and she gives me the look so
I'm just standing there taking it
because I don't want to freak out Mariel
by getting mad and I'm just taking spit
to my face ah so much spit I'm talking
about if he was a pastor he would have
baptized my [__] ass so once again this
close to my face
[__] screaming his lungs out and I'm
like you know what dude listen calm down
I don't see any damages on the car but
if there is something and the damages go
above my deductible then you could take
it out of my insurance if it's below
then I'll pay it out of pocket no
worries here's my information take it
man it's all my fault I completely
understand that doesn't calm him down
he's still screaming in my [__] face
now mind you I'm still calm I look over
at Mariel I'm like hey now my dude
there's a lot of you out there that
probably would a deck this full but I'm
an adult I'm like look it's my fault and
I'm somebody who believes if it's your
fault you got to take what's coming to
you just let him vent it out so the last
thing he yells at me is go down there
and check it out now at this point I'm
getting really pissed cuz he's talking
to me like I'm his [__] butt sling go
down there and check it out what the
[__] am I trying to suck your dick so as
I go down to look at it he goes you know
what just get the [__] out my way puts
his hands on my chest and pushes me out
the way now this sir is where you [__]
up now I'm completely ok with the
yelling but you sir decided to put your
hands on my trying to get [__] in the
ass right now [__] what my image it was
one of those moments the earrings
snapping off heels coming now I don't
got a gun but i'ma pray to Jesus to come
down with a bazooka and destroy your
[__] family moment so at this point
even Mariola shock I look at her and she
goes shits about to pop off and it's
funny too because in general I consider
myself a [__] now like I won't fight
and in fact I don't think I can't
anymore I think I'm just a big ass dude
but if you grew up throwing fists and
fighting people your whole life that
apparently doesn't go away it's just a
part of you and those habits are really
hard to break so I wanted to the dude
went to his face I said see now I got a
[__] you up and it's late too cuz the
moment I said that his attitude changed
he was like whoa whoa whoa I don't know
what's going on right now but you seemed
really mad now my jus
he pushed me and now he suddenly has
amnesia he doesn't know what's going on
so I reiterated what I said before which
is the little extra pizzazz and I said
you put your [__] hands on me which
means you want to throw down so back the
[__] away from my car so I can focus up
I don't know how does she came out my
mouth but I was like you know what you
go girl [__] then of course his reaction
is to suddenly try to calm me down he
goes whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't know
what I said to offend you or anything
like that
but I'm completely sorry I didn't mean
to do that and it's so funny how
somebody can talk big say whatever the
[__] they want put their hands on
somebody but until they're confronted
they start to shrivel up like a little
[__] nutsack and now as I'm in this
dude's face I'm pushing away from my car
and he starts to like cower in fear his
wife comes out and she's like everybody
calm down
blah blah blah blah blah and tries to
put her hands on me telling me to relax
now I'm so [__] mad I look at her and
I'm like you know what dude you need to
get the [__] away from me before you get
yo far away I didn't mean to threaten
her it was just kind of like a chain
reaction [__] you like [__]
hmm but you want to know the [__] the
thing was after all of it was said and
done I apologized to do we shook hands I
came up to shake the lady's hand she
just completely snubbed me and then went
into her car
oh that very moment I kind of wish I had
a pill that could turn myself into a
woman just so I could get in her face
and be like what's up [__] now we gonna
do this I'm a [__] to with a scratch
your eyes out but yes that was my little
tokyo showdown so just remember if
you're in LA and you park next to a
bright orange mini cooper just walk up
to the guy say hey your car's a mistake
anyway so why the [__] do you care
oh yeah look I don't have jealousy
issues but hypothetically speaking if a
man or woman watched into my homes and
he or she happens to have hey dick yeah
might have a problem yeah yeah that is
exactly why all my male friends think
they can eat them because I do hate them